l'uafa bonjour alors sur quoi a été
questionné le premier ministre
alors amis a comme on s'y attendait
évidemment la question de cette crise
sanitaire sans précédent était au coeur
de ces questions au gouvernement en
format restreint comme on l'a dit un
évidement notamment la question de la
gestion des masques d'ailleurs le
premier ministre a été interrogé à
plusieurs reprises un par plusieurs
groupes donc lé socialiste ou lui des
jeux propose d'écouter edouard philippe
j'ai compris de ce que disent les
autorités de santé que le port du masque
en population générale n'était pas à
recommander
il n'est pas recommandé d'abord parce
que l'utilité du port du masque en
population générale
autrement dit lorsqu'on se promène dans
la rue lorsque on respecte les gestes
barrière lorsqu'on respecte les
distances de sécurité
il n'est pas recommandé car il est
inutile et qu'il prive ceux qui ont
besoin des masques parce que leurs
activités les places dans des situations
qui ne sont pas celles de la population
générale
les soigner ont bien entendu tous ceux
qui sont directement au contact des
malades ou les malades eux mêmes déclaré
afin de limiter la propagation de virus
un grand nombre de professionnels de
santé ont pu depuis deux jours à les
voir leurs officines pour prendre des
masques avec une logique de rationnement
qui a été présenté à chaque syndicat à
chaque corporation et j'ajoute pardon du
président qui vit à 17 millions de
masques qui ont également été livrés
depuis hier soir
aujourd'hui et demain à l'ensemble des
hôpitaux des grosses des groupement
hospitalier de territoire des ehpad et
des organismes de transports sanitaires
de notre pays ce qui fait au total près
de 30 millions de masques qui ont été
déstocker et livrés depuis maintenant
trois jours alors la gestion sanitaire
mais aussi la gestion économique et
également les sanctions à l'encontre de
ceux qui ne respectent pas les consignes
voici quelques points qui ont été
évoquées par les députés 1 ce matin et
puis le président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand a tenu à
montrer qu'il tenait à coeur à ce que la
vie démocratique se poursuive malgré ce
virus qui se propage de jour en jour
merci à lee la fa pour toutes ces
précisions vous retrouve certainement
à l'heure